Yeah. I take women back a hundred years.
I'm like, "No, I'm the clear example of
how to be empowered. I use my body. I do
what I want when I want. And this is a
thing you've been banging on about for
years. I hate like when I click on the
comments of these women that like, oh,
you're taking us back 100 years." Then
in their bio, it says stay at home mom
of two. I'm thinking, what the [__] was
you rooting for? Because you have just
stayed at home. That's right, Bonnie.
See, this is the future. Yeah. I'm I'm
This is the future. This is fantastic.
It's exactly what it what Western
societyy's headed to.
Did you see it?
By the grace of Allah subhana wa ta'ala,
we did it. You did it. We have exceeded
our target of 2 million, jumping from
1.7 to 2.4 million from just two
donations. Something deeper than
generosity is at play here. And that's
belief. Belief that this matters, that
it's worth investing in, and that it is
permanent and it is here to stay
inshallah.
[Music]
Asalam alaikum guys. Alhamdulillah
sisters. I come from a jah but believe
me guys I don't think I've been anywhere
close to these two individuals
especially that woman body whatever her
name is. The prophetam said in a hadith
the prevalence of fornication and
adultery along with drinking of alcohol
is a sign approaching the hour. Brother
sisters, one of the signs of the hour is
that zena will be so prevalent that uh
a person having zena in the middle of
the road and the best amongst them the
prophet said will be someone who saying
go and do it behind the wall. Here's a
video of Andrew Tate's discussion with
this bony woman and we're going to see
inshallah and I'm going to say I say
alhamdulillah because degeneracy and a
man following his desires this is what
it brings it down to. This is what
feminism, red pill, man-made laws, and
man-made morality, and man-made I think
I know best brings you to. Here's the
video. Let's see what we can learn from
it, inshallah. Say, alhamdulillah, for
Islam. What do you think of Bonnie Blue
sleeping with 157 men? How honest should
I be out of 10? I want you to be honest.
You want me to be honest? Honest. Yeah.
Go on.
I don't understand why men sit here and
try and lecture you about it. I don't
understand why men sit here and say you
shouldn't do it. It's your body, your
choice, right? This is the world we now
live in. This is the end result of
feminism. You are the perfect end result
of feminism. In the world I believe in
in the conservative traditionally
masculinely ruled world, a man would be
in charge of his daughters until they're
handed over to their husbands or
boyfriends and there would be a degree
of masculine guidance. But feminism
didn't want that. You know, women
complained that men don't want to get
married. We did actually want to get
married when we got obedient virgins,
but they disappeared. and they
complained about the patriarchy and they
were tired of us giving them a house to
live in and kids to raise and they
wanted to make their own choices. So,
she's making her own choice. That's a
fantastic thing. I mean, Andrew Tate's
being uh smart about this. Obviously,
you guys know my difference with Andrew
Tate. Um, but I agree when it comes to
gender roles, there's a lot of truths
that he speaks, not all, which we're
going to find out today. But, as you can
see, subhan Allah, feminism, this is the
byproduct of feminism. This is the end
result of feminism. Your body, your
choice, do whatever you like. 157 men,
no problem. You're a walking toilet.
That's what you are. Men ejaculate. Yes.
Okay. Just like they go to the toilet.
Number one. Number two, why can they
relieve theirself? What's a toilet? It's
an inanimate object. And that's the
reason why the western system has made
women inanimate objects. That's what
they are. And there's studies that
showed us this. There was a study done
in university where they showed men
women in bikini and the part of the
brain that lit up for tool use. They see
them as inanimate objects. That's why
you are walking talking toilet because
men come relieve the inside of you and
say bye-bye. It's why it's disgusting.
And like Andrew Tate said, before it
would be the man, my daughters are my
responsibility, my protection. I have to
protect my daughters, my wife, my
sister. Okay, they are under my
protection. It's my job to make sure
that the man that I choose for them, so
it goes from one responsibility to
another. That's the reason why Allah has
given one um level above a man in that
responsibility cuz it is something that
we have. It's not something it's a perk.
It's a responsibility. Alhamdulillah.
That's how it used to be. Well, that's
what feminist has done. Enjoy it. What
if it was your daughter? Well, that
won't happen. But she's her own person.
I never said my daughter's her own
person. I said I said women want to be
their own people. But my point is
there's so many women who go to Magalof
for a weekend and do something very
similar and then they come back to
England and get with some [__] guy
and start asking for presents from him
and talking about how they deserve a
traditional relationship and they want
to get married and they want a Christmas
present and all this [__] Most
women do exactly what Bonnie does. I
don't see you any different than most
women. And I'm not saying that in a
degree. Most women don't sleep with a,57
men in a day. 1,000 does it [__]
matter? I think it does. I don't really
think it does.
It's all disgusting to me. I mean, yes,
of course it is in that sense, but it is
disgusting. Um, you know, if a person is
having committing dinner, you know, one
thing you need to understand with men as
well, cuz there you can see his
protective jealousy coming out. This is
natural inclination to men. Men have
been stripped of this. I was speaking to
men. We're like, no, my sister can go
and do what she likes to. I'm like, what
are you talking about? You've been
programmed to say that. You don't in
your natural inclination or behavior or
psychology are okay with somebody doing
stuff to your sister or your daughter or
your mother or your wife. You don't.
That's not normal. That's not normal at
all. So the thing is it's the system has
penetrated them uh no pun intended in a
specific way brother and sisters that
they have succumb to this. They become
wimps. Men have become absolute wimps.
That's why you can see subhan Allah it
is so so important um that we have these
traits and you can see it and take
because he's talking about that. So one
thing that he said for example um about
1,000 or 15 I mean the number obviously
I'll be honest with you like after a
certain amount it's just like you know
it's it does it doesn't change. Just be
honest with people just watching you
slept with what five people an average
western woman sleeps anywhere from 9 to
15 people that Yeah. What's the
difference? 9 15 1,000 after a specific
number it's done. Do you get what I'm
trying to say? It's like oh woman's a a
a a a prostitute. Yeah. It doesn't
matter that when once a label's given
now it's like oh no just like 9 10 who
cares. It does matter. It does matter
for both men and women. It does matter.
The idea of having a bunch of men a
woman that you're with is pretty
repulsive. Everyone has a past. But see,
this is the kind of [__] white people
say. This is I don't know what's wrong
with you people. Everyone has a past.
That's not acceptable. Well, there you
go. This is exactly I mean, I have to
agree with him. When you mean white,
talking about the Western uh men in
general, what do you mean by she has a
past? What the hell is this? You've been
programmed to think this. This is not
normal. This is not normal at all. Men
would not accept this kind of stuff.
Let's be honest with you, men judge a
woman by her past. That's a reality.
That's our psychology. That's how we
think. We don't like it. Women judge us
by our future. What career we're going
to have, what we're going to do, what
kind of provider we're going to be, are
we going to get married again? 1 2 3 4.
Yes. the for the woman that sisters come
and say that you should not judge a
woman by your past. Then why do you guys
judge us by our future? If a brother
came and said I want to get married
again, what would you do? Uhuh. I'm not
marrying him. Why is it that you have a
right to do that? But a man when he says
okay you've been with two I don't want
that for myself. Why is it one rule for
you one for another? That's what I mean
by the the imbalance here. We need to be
just if you can judge a man because he
wants to get married again. Okay, that's
up to you. You don't want to marry him.
A man can have every right to come and
say, "Okay, you know what? You've had
more than one two sexual partners. I I
don't want that for myself." It's
absolutely right because we are
different beings. Yes, you cannot make
them the same. Let's understand that
guys in weird way that the men the the
the Brit the western men have done this
and they are suffering like dogs. They
cannot deal with they cannot deal with
the reality in their life knowing that
their wife has went around the block.
They don't like it but they can't do
nothing about it. You ask for it. I'm
not here to tell you I take women back
100 years and I'm like no I'm the clear
example of how to be empowered. I use my
body. I do what I want when I want. And
this is a thing you've been banging on
about for years. Doing own god knows
what to. And you're telling me this is
empowerment. This is what feminism. This
is where the trajectory goes. That's the
reason why the dust of feminism is
coming to our households. Muslim men are
being affected by this. Why? Because
their wives become miss boss boss babe
spend slay the day babe. Yes.
Alhamdulillah. This that etc. Subhan
Allah. They want the best of both
worlds. You know, subhan Allah. A bit of
this, a bit of feminism and a bit of
Islam. They can't have it both ways.
Subhan Allah. So you can see this is
what it has done. This is the end result
of feminism. She thinks that's
empowerment.
Empowerment makes me sick. It's
repulsive.
Hate. Like when I click on the comments
of these women that like, oh, you're
taking us back 100 years. Then in their
bio it says stay at home mom of two. I'm
think what the [__] was you rooting for
because you have just stayed at home.
That's right, Bonnie. See, this is the
future. Yeah, I'm I'm This is the
future. This is fantastic. It's exactly
what it what Western societyy's headed
to. It's interesting moving
strategically by Oh, yeah. Go ahead.
She's talking about taking you uh that
woman blame her for that they went back
100 years went back 100 years for what
we talking about 100 years ago the woman
alhamdulillah British woman British
woman were wearing hijabs they were
dressed up decently yes they did not
they were not promiscuous they were not
like that there was a video that was
shown um you might see on the screen
yeah which they showed these kind of
girls um on a mannequin a a low cut top
and they all like oh which kind of woman
would wear that skimpy this that etc
disgusting
right any any girl with any decency.
He'd never walk in the street with them
on. But they might wear one of the
disgusting. Why? Well, I don't know.
It's really disgusting. I wouldn't wear
one. Try and catch any more.
Well, I think it's just a gimmick. And
um I don't think any girl in their right
mind would wear it. I don't think any
decent girl would wear one. I mean, they
might be all right for these Debbie
types in London at these parties, but I
don't think they'll catch on in Wolver.
That was their natural incarnation. For
a woman to have modesty, it is natural
for them. For a man to have protective
jealousy was natural. That is being
stripped away from the woman. And that's
the reason why when you corrupt the
woman, the society at whole corrupts.
That's why it's so important Islam gives
a great emphasis to protecting the
woman. Because he knows when the woman
goes down, it all goes down. My daughter
just wouldn't make that decision. But
why? Because I still raise her in a
household where she is masculinely
guided and she will be guided by me
until I hand her over to some other man.
However, I believe when women are left
to their own devices, they will only
ever make stupid decisions. I mean, I
don't agree with the word stupid, but I
do believe that when women go to other
women, they destroy theel. I believe
women lead other women to destruction.
That's why I always tell brothers, do
not let your wife have certain friends
or let me be honest with you or go get
advice from those friends specifically
about your relationship. She should not
be speaking to her friends about your
relationship, your marriage, etc. And if
she's got these kind of friends, cut
them off immediately. Why? Because women
are a feminine energy. Yes. The feminine
is a flow. Yes. Okay. And that's the
reason why it needs a man that's
certain. Yes. It needs a man that leads.
That's the reason why sisters is so
important because what happens is a
woman has emotions. Yes. She goes
through emotional imbalances. And the
next thing she needs is to go to a
friend who's on a period, not having a
good time, is single, doesn't like the
fact, and women compete with each other.
Be honest. The biggest enemy to woman is
other women. Yes. Okay. They go to their
friend who's single, cannot find
somebody. She's married.
She herself is married. Her friend is
not. She's on her period. Disaster. Oh,
my husband said this. How dare he?
Because deep down she's like she's gone
through emotional imbalance. So, she's
like, "Okay, you know what? You should
not put up with her. You can do better."
Why? Cuz she just wants a friend. She
wants a friend. She's single. Nobody
wants her. She wants a friend. She wants
a companion. Misery loves companion from
sisters company. So that's the reason
why I advise men not to advise uh women
to not advise other women specifically.
Go to your family male members in if
you're having a dispute with your
husband or go to a a woman in your
household or someone that you know that
is mature that's had good marriage
experience 10 20 years and is still
married. A minor stupid decision. I
wouldn't say it's any more stupid than
most decisions women make to be honest
with you. I think that most women to
some degree are sex workers anyway. Like
let's let's be honest. Yeah. So here I
don't know what on earth Andrew is
talking about. They're all sex workers.
What is it about Andre? Your mom, your
daughter, your sisters. If you have
sisters
they are you trying to call them sex
workers. Are you okay? I don't I do.
What do you mean by this? Let's find
out. Right. Most women look at Miami or
Dubai. What's your job? Oh, I've got a
boyfriend. So your job is being a
girlfriend. And why does he give you
money? Cuz you give him sex. So most
most women are sex workers anyway. So
one second. So they're sex workers
because they give intimacy to their
husbands. So anyone so I don't
understand why would you wear that
connotation that word sex work that
conotation can I come and say okay you
know okay so what does that mean so
you're going to call prostitutes you're
going to say okay oh my mom is my dad's
prostitute or my sister is a husband's
prostitute my daughter is a husband why
would you use such a word it's so
bizarre and not only that um you know
our wives get intimacy from us are we
sex workers as well I'm a sex I'm a
jigler what am I like I'm a sex worker I
don't understand what does something
speak for the sake of it I agree with a
lot of stuff when it comes to gender
role But it's very weird and it's
nothing to do with Islam. But isn't that
what you said the family unit was? Well,
then you're a sex worker with one
customer. I don't understand. Like he
contradicts himself. Family unit and now
it's I don't know what to say, you know,
which is nice. I guess it's better. It's
more efficient. But what about if you're
raising children? That's not sex work,
is it? No, that's being a mother. Yeah,
that's being a mother. So now that's
being a mother. You're you're you're a
prostitute, but at the same time, you're
a mother.
I I I don't know. I don't know what All
right. So that's interesting. Rob Rob
said this, not me. So they're either
virgins, sex workers, or mothers. Are
those are those the three categories? I
think you're putting words into my
mouth. I think that's what Rob just
said. Those are the three categories.
I'm just sat in the middle. And women
have to choose to be one of them. Yeah.
This is nothing to do with Islam. Just
to make it clear. Nothing to do with
Islam at all. No way, shape or form. So
is that what you think? I think that
when a woman becomes a mother, she has a
purpose. And I think that women should
be having children as soon as possible.
And I think it gives their life a
direction. And I think it's the most
important thing to preserve society,
especially if you want to talk about
geopolitics and talk about race and all
of these things. If you want to have a
country that looks like the country it
used to be, you need to have the
original people from there having
children. I so yes, I agree with this
like for women and this is why I always
advise sisters to get married young, get
rid of look the feminist world, the
western woman, the white woman is
regretting going down the route of
career path. They have been lied to.
This is why we talk about women are
easily manipulated. They have been lied
to. Career woman, boss woman, read it.
Women do not want to work. There was a
large study done. Yes. Okay. Many places
these studies show that women do not
like to work. They don't want to work.
And they have been told Miss
Independent, your boss, fave, go stay.
What happens is they reach and they
don't understand their biological clock
is ticking. And I don't mean this in
offensive way. This is a reality. Your
biological clock is ticken. You should
get the kids out the way. And then when
your kids are a bit older, then you can
go back to if you want to go do a
career. Well, if not, at least you've
got kids, you've got a husband, someone
that takes care of you, then you can go
back to it. Don't do it the opposite way
around. And that's the reason why so
many women are suffering there. Do you
know how many women are going to be
single and uh without children? That's
not in a woman's nature. A woman wants
to Yes. When she's ovulating, she wants
to she wants to procreate in a right
way. It should be done. And believe me,
I see the joy in my wife's eyes when
she's with our children. I see it. Come
on, guys. Women go around use sex to
their advantage but then are happy to
cry about it straight away saying oh you
took advantage of me. It's like you're
the one that wanted to do sex to have
like the job promotion or you're the one
that wanted to have sex to get more
attention or try and be more light, but
then they cry about it. And that's what
I get frustrated about. And even with
porn stars, like people in my industry,
they'll do this for a few years, get the
money, get the boob jobs, get the house,
and then suddenly they go, "Oh my god, I
was forced into the industry. Oh my god,
someone took all my money." I mean,
sadly, this is a again, it's a it's a
reality in what sense? Because women
don't like accountability in many
aspects. in this specific aspect you go
down this industry pornography adult
industry whatever it is for that matter
do what you need to do and then
afterwards oh no it was I was no you
wasn't you're a grown adult you have to
take accountability take accountability
okay you don't want to take
accountability you go doing things you
don't want to do and where does this
stem from a woman's hay in a woman's
modesty hay cuz I come from a jahal no
woman is going to come and say to you I
want even the most hish my language hish
of the whole females who were behaving
that way none of them come and say I
want you to sleep with me they do it
covertly because they have the higher
element, the natural inclination of
modesty. Why? Cuz that's how women are.
And when they would go and do that,
because they would act like they don't
want to. When they do, they'll blame it
on the man. Women need to take
accountability for these actions. Like
Mia Khalifa. Oh, I went there. I didn't
know. Yes, you did. You knew exactly
what he's doing. You wanted attention
when they should run out. Oh, I didn't
know. You're the victim now. You're not
the victim. Take accountability. It's
very important that women take
accountability when it comes to these
specific actions, specific entering this
industry. You're not stupid. So, women
are for money all the time anyway.
That's all women do now. The entire
Western world is women for money. So how
hypocritical would it be for me to sit
here and say Bonnie who's honest, who
monetizes it directly with her own media
empire, who's upfront about it and makes
money from it, is a worse person than
the girl who walks around like she's
goody two shoes and then okay, so here's
here's he's basically saying I agree and
disagree in that sense, but he's
basically saying the western women are
doing this anyways. And if you think
about it, it is right because if you
look at the average western woman, she's
sleeping with 9 to 15 plus woman men in
in in in a lifetime or maybe even more.
I mean, back in the days, woman like
that would be called a prostitute. Yes.
So, he's saying basically she's at least
monetizing it. She's she's going to
Okay, you might say 1,50 man. No. Okay,
maybe I'm not saying that. However,
after a certain amount, you need to
understand the way zimma affects a woman
is not the same affects a man. Doesn't
mean in Islam they derely different. No,
in Islam if a man or a woman have sex
outside of marriage, they are capital
punishment. If they are single and they
have it, they'll be lashing. They'll get
lashed 100 lashes. Yes. And the
punishment in the hereafter is the same.
In the sight of God, you are the same.
The punishment is the same. The the
crime is the same. However, the way
affects a woman is not the way it
affects a man. This doesn't give a man
to go ahead. The way a woman is
affected, it shows that if a woman has
more than four sexual partners in her
life, her success rate of marriage and
success goes from 90% to 20%. Which
shows that we need to understand women
are emotional. The way they she's
created that intimate bond. Yes. Because
she released oxytocin in her body. It's
it's a bonding hormone. Yes. Okay. So
when that happens, you need to
understand that's the reason why a lot
of men avoid going for women who have a
deep past or they've been with a man for
so long because you know why? Cuz she
has deeply bonded with that man and
she's going to look for that man in that
new uh uh the new husband. So that's the
reason why a lot of men avoid single
mothers or women who have been divorced
etc. Why? Because of this reason. the
way it affects a woman is not the same
as it affects a man. Um, so that's the
reason why Andrew Tate is saying that at
least she's monetizing. Again, in Islam,
it is wrong. Wrong. This is haram and
this is a disgusting way of life. Subhan
Allah. Have you slept with 157 women at
least?
So, are you quite similar? Absolutely
not. Okay. This is disgusting because
you know why this is absolute nonsense?
Cuz in Islam, you can't come and say
that. You see the way you're proud. The
prophetam said all of son of Adam will
be forgiven except those who mention
their sins. You're boasting. You're
boasting. I come from a Yeah. It's not
something I'm proud. It's actually
something disgusting. I I'm I'm ashamed
of. Not only that, I wish I never went
through it. Yeah. But subhan Allah of I
did and I saw I was in the dark and I
saw light. That's why I'm so
alhamdulillah attached to Islam because
I know how dark it can be. I know girls
like Bunny um you know in clubs etc.
They're depressed. They are depressed. I
promise you they are so depressed. They
have no trajectory in life. They have no
compass. They are absolutely lost.
sleeping around men throwing them around
like a piece of meat garbage here and
there etc. using abusing them. It is so
disgusting. And I've seen women like
Bonnie broken down, finished either turn
into drugs, suicide, and God knows what.
Subhan Allah. So for him to come and say
it's not the uh it's not the same. You
cannot say that. Yes. Okay. In Islam,
you will get the same punishment as her.
You are as bad as her. 1,000. It's
nothing to be proud of. Why not? Because
it's the male's prerogative to
impregnate as many females as possible.
This is the masculine prerogative. This
is biologically my prerogative is to do
that. So here is he is right in a sense
where it is the man's natural
inclination to want to procreate but not
in this disgusting way. Yes, a man is
there why taking care of his family
household. Okay, procreate. Yes, he can
have one wife, two wife, three wife,
four wife and Islam has given a limit.
Not you can cause chaos and go
everywhere. No, because it's all
responsibility. So those four wives,
they all have rights. You have to marry
them all. You have to give them mahad.
You need to speak to their fathers. You
need to give them rights. You need to
pay for the bills. All that kind of
stuff. Why it's limited to four? because
it's given that the the Jew right the
basic Jew right because we even spend
two days with each each one of them okay
roughly so subhan Allah at least there's
some kind of rights and h given to them
okay that's the reason why God has
limited it and it's very important for
us to understand it's not matchless guys
okay as a man we need to understand that
this is our job our duty to look after
our families so yes we have the
inclination to procreate that's norm
that's why I say every man is polygamous
by nature but not every man can do
polygamy okay which is something I
should add on to what that statement
that I So yes, but anyways, let's carry
on. So do you think you're a good role
model for women? I'm a clear example of
what women have fought for for years of
taking control of your body. Correct.
Being independent. I am my own money. I
don't rely on a guy. I'm Exactly. I'm
paid more than other guys. Do you do you
think she is a clear example of what
women have been fighting for for years?
Absolutely correct. Exactly. And who
benefits from that? Men Men love this.
The reason why Look, she has an
empowerment, etc. You know who benefits
from it? Men. Cuz men come and say,
"Yeah, you go, girl. Dress up how you
like, minus skirt cuz that's like that's
what we like to see. And guess what?
When you do that and act loose, we get
sex for free. You know why? Cuz before
you get married, speak to your father.
That's long, man. Cheat code. Boom. I
can get what I want without getting
married all day, every day. Men love to
see it. They see you naked, etc. Half
naked, looking at you, uh, checking you
out, sexualizing you. 97% of British
women have been sexually assaulted one
way or another. So the men are
benefiting from that. You don't get
nothing. Nada. And after that, after
they get what they want, they call you
what? A-ho. That's what it And Islam has
come to protect the family unit. Islam
has come to protect your heart. You as a
woman. Look what the western world has
done to you. And Islam is the problem.
Islam is there to save you guys. Islam
is there to give you the right
trajectory in life. And that's the
reason why Andrew say, "Yeah, you go.
Okay, man. Save the day. What can you
do?" You know, cuz it benefits people
like And benefits them. The western
world, this is feminism. This is what
all you white boys wanted. All you white
men listening to women all the time,
women get to opinions all of a sudden.
This is what you built. Congratulations.
So you blame Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
Exactly. I'm so sorry. That's what you
wanted and it comes at a cost because
when people the the the western man has
promoted this and made this uh seem
legitimate and okay, guess what? Who's
suffering? He is. Because when he's
marrying his wife now, he's like, "Oh,
damn. She's being round the block." He
doesn't like that. Not only that, her
being round the block has consequences
now because she's now comparing his, you
know, private part sizes. He's comparing
his performance in the bed. He's
comparing his kids, his looks and
everything about it to the past 9 10 11
12 15 20 or in Bonnie's case 157 men and
she's saying I'm not happy and woman
like you said before that's where Allah
has given the power of divorce for a
woman because a woman can be there's
unstability she can be emotional ask for
divorce and not only that she's now
comparing you to all of those other men
and what's happening now the destruction
of the family unit alhamdulillah Islam
that's all I can say well 100% I blame
men because everything's men's fault cuz
men are the only ones who can apply
force to scenarios Women can't apply
force. Men apply force. If there's
something we don't like, we apply force
to the situation. We could force this
away. We could force most things away.
So everything's absolutely men's fault.
I mean, I 100% agree with him. When
brothers come to me and say, oh,
argument sake, you know, Rick, case
scenario, oh my wife was disloyal or for
example, my wife is disrespecting me. I
mean, every woman disrespects their
husband to a certain level, but I'm
talking about deep disrespect.
Disrespect me. All doesn't listen.
Listen, I blame him. I said, bro, it's
your fault. You know why? Because when
you married her, she pushed the limits.
You didn't have no boundaries. You
didn't have a a a backbone. That's the
reason why. And women, guess what? They
will never tell you. They'll say, "Oh, I
don't like a man. I like a man that
tells yes to everything." Bull crap.
Women are known to say things they don't
mean. When they say yes, it means no.
When it means no. When they say no, it
means yes. When it means no, it means
maybe. Yes. So, it depends. So, you need
to understand as a man, I blame you
because you are supposed to be the
leader. You are supposed to be the
leader in the house. You have to be
corner shot. For example, with my wife,
when my wife's got certain things
missing in the house, I have to go get
it. Yes. Okay. The the bin, I throw it
out. Okay. Um, she her charger recently
broke. I had to go make sure that she's
got a charger. I cater for her. I run
around for her. Why? Because she's my uh
wife. She's under my care. I need to
make sure what she needs, she gets. What
she needs, she gets, not what she wants,
she gets. Okay. And of course, there's
certain things that I like to treat my
wife as well. That's not an issue. Yes,
I fixed the cupboard. For example, I
bought a massive cupboard. Yes. Okay.
This home is £300 for someone to come
fix. I said, "No, thank you. I don't
have £300 to give anybody." Yes. I had
to fix it myself. It took me nearly 13
and a half hours. I fixed it.
Alhamdulillah. When it comes to the bunk
bed of the kids, I fix it. When the car
gets broken down, I fix it. When certain
things, I fix it. Alhamdulillah. But
when it comes to obedience, I expect
obedience as well. Okay? When it comes
to leadership, I'm the leader. I'm the
one who gives the last say in the
matter. Why? This doesn't mean my wife
doesn't have a say, but I have the last
say. This is how the dynamics work.
Subhan Allah. And that this doesn't mean
before brothers come and say, "Oh, Ali."
So, no. When it comes to changing my
daughter's nappies, I do change it. When
it comes to brushing their hair, I do
brush the hair. When it comes to feeding
them, I do. Sometimes my wife has to go
certain places um go out etc. I look
after them. There has to be a fine
balance guys. Don't go to the other
extreme of red pill or like make it seem
like no your wife is your companion.
Don't treat her any other way. So it's
important that I blame men cuz if you
don't have the backbone to have
boundaries and uh make sure that you say
when you say no it's a no then my friend
let me tell you something. Not only
would your wife would be disgusted from
you, you have no backbone. She would
disrespect you. And let me tell you
something if she cheats I'll blame you.
Nobody else. So why should I sit there
and think [__] I should do something to
help you? I don't care. I should focus
on myself. And if more people did that,
the world would actually be a better
place. But they come so fixated on other
people. I'm like, where's your life? Why
are you not focusing on yourself? Like
look in the mirror. You're fat. Go and
do something about it. Your teeth have
that much plaque on it. Like you're
[__] If somebody if everyone focused
on the self, it' be a better place. What
the hell are you talking about? What
kind of stupidity is this? This the
hedenism of the Western world. Absolute
hedonism. Myself, my selfishness. My
It's all about me. Brothers and sisters,
wai. What can I say uh in this aspect?
Subhan Allah. All I just want to say is
guys nothing else to say. Alhamdulillah
for Islam and subhan Allah the prophetam
said if you have no shame do as you
please. We have Islam and alhamdulillah
come fromah not close to these at all
but wall what a depressed and disgusting
life bro. Alhamdulillah for Islam.
Alhamdulillah for Islam. Wallah you do
not understand how precious Islam is.
And these guys are a fine example of the
degeneracy. Alhamdulillah, Islam is
trying to save them from this while
Zionists are pumping into porn industry,
gambling industry, alcohol industry,
etc. to destroy your youth. And you got
Tom Robertson saying that Islam is the
biggest threat. You scumbag. Till next
time. to lie with medic.